every day is a struggle for layla her
husband left afghanistan for around five
months ago to look for a job and she
hasn't heard from him since
she's living in a makeshift camp in
kandahar city with her two sons and her
brother-in-law's family
ramadan is coming and we have nothing to
eat during this month it is hard to fast
eating only bread my kids are sick and i
don't have enough money to buy their
medicine i collect garbage and bottles
from the street from morning until
evening and i barely make the equivalent
of 35 cents which is not enough to buy
flour oil or rice for dinner the number
of people in afghanistan who can't
afford food and other essentials has
doubled since the taliban took over last
year
the un's humanitarian agency says 4.4
billion dollars is needed in afghanistan
as it faces an economic crash and
humanitarian crisis
the money is needed to boost the
delivery of food and agricultural
support and to fund health services
water and sanitation and education
afghans need our help
enabling their economy
sustaining their agriculture and
enabling the basic functioning of social
services to prevent further economic
collapse and preserve those basic
services the international community has
long said human rights must be upheld
for the taliban-led government to
receive aid
those supporting the un appeal say the
taliban's decision to close most
secondary schools for girls last week
has made it more difficult to raise
funds from western governments
the taliban the de facto authorities
have to live up
to their responsibility to protect their
people and to help humanitarian
organizations
do the work on the ground that they need
to do
for decades afghanistan was heavily
reliant on financial aid that was frozen
when the taliban took power
now the un is urging the world not to
forget the country as it faces a crisis
victoria gatenbee al jazeera